greetings from [ __ ] podcast
Ville it's July 9th [ __ ] get
your [ __ ] together
the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by hymns listen
66% of men start to lose their hair by
the age of 35 once you notice thinning
hair it's too late is that hairline
slowly starting to move backwards any
bald spots yet I got the solution for
hems calm a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men listen
to me no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements just prescription
solutions backed by science now today
the church family can get started with
hymns with a complete hair kit for just
$5 listen it's tough losing your hair
and when you're young you're losing your
hair it's not a good feeling I
understand but listen we got help with
science now and it starts with for
Emma's calm what we're gonna do is give
you a complete head kit for just five
dollars that's right you heard it right
five dollars to get started right now
while supplies last and subject to a
doctor's approval you got to see the
website for full details and safety
information now this could cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor you
know that and I know that and if you
went to a doctor or pharmacy or
somewhere else you gotta be embarrassed
and whatnot in your head do forget about
that now go to hims for hims calm slash
Joey right now Jo ey that's for hims
calm slash Joey again for hims doc calm
calm slash Joey they'll take care you
well whatever you were from hair loss to
skins care from sexual wellness that's
for hims calm slash Joey the church or
what's happened now it's also brought to
you by one of the best supplement
companies out there in the country on it
you're sitting there going Joey why
should I go to on it why because you're
sitting there scratching your head
thinking about what you forgot that
don't happen without it you know why
they got out for brain if you don't like
you get one hundred percent money-back
money percent hundred-percent money-back
guarantee
alpha brain is made from nootropics it
gets deep into your mind and makes you
little bit more focus remembers things
you know [ __ ] like that give it a shot
make sure Lert beside that they got the
shroom TechSoup port and the shroom tech
immune which I live off by you know me
I'm on [ __ ] planes you know around
all these [ __ ] people with gas masks
on and [ __ ] they don't wash their
[ __ ] hands that [ __ ] all ends with
shroom tech immune it tip-top Magoo's
your [ __ ] immune system so you won't
get sick and you got shroom tech sport
for enhanced breathing more lung
capacity and stuff like that listen I
can't explain everything to you I'm not
a genius
go to an ER comrade now look at the fine
selection of supplements they got the
bats take out the kettlebells I can't
help you with that
but as far as supplements are concerned
I got you 10% off to live at the house
just go to adam.com
right now press charge CH you are CH and
get 10% off your first order delivered
to your [ __ ] house take this
[ __ ] melee Chris you're flexing
the house from the [ __ ] one of the
top five bands in the world in my [ __ ]
in the world the Foo Fighters how are
you brother good man how you doing thank
you for taking the time out you know
this is an honor
oh thanks for having me when I Justin
called me and asked me I was like eh you
[ __ ] kidding me I watched that video
I've watched you on that video thousands
of times
yeah all right on you know that's a
great [ __ ] about all the videos all
the it's just amazing the whole I joined
up with him you had a call [ __ ] yeah I
just auditioned you know like I was just
one of a one of a bunch of guys that
that was lucky enough to get an audition
and not too far from here actually
there's a little rehearsal studio out
here in the valley called mates and I
went in there and and like played a few
songs and then went back to San
Francisco and then Kate I was living in
San Francisco at the time and then came
back down a week later and had a sort of
a more extensive audition and and then
they let me know the next day and I got
the gig and it's been kind of okay then
chug along ever since
just a sweet surfer guy from Santa
Barbara now one of the world's greatest
rock and roll bands it's funny because
I've read a couple of your things and
seen a couple you and I don't want to
beat the same
interview but a friend asked you if you
wanted to audition for guns and you're
like yeah but I heard that because you
are is split from fool can you get me an
audition there that was oh it's funny
because you like that that thing I've
told that story before and it's sort of
evolved on the Internet into this into
this internet rumor that you weren't
good yeah that I was yeah that I was
either in the guy I was gonna be in
which none of that's true at all and you
have to like it's sort of hard to
remember in context of like 1999 that
was like you know Guns N'Roses was it
was axial and like a bunch of other guys
there was like no slash no Duff no yes
you know that like it was many years
after all that so had like Guns and
Roses in 1987 but at the time you know I
was like you know my buddy bill just
knew somebody that knew somebody that
could maybe could have got me an
audition for whatever sort of version of
it what's happening then so that that
was it and I just said you know I heard
Foo Fighters need a guitar player and so
he wanted to help him me get an audition
didn't ever dream of being because you
came basically from Punk yes I mean I
grew up listening to like classic rock
heavy metal you know it's sort of stuff
and then you know punk rock just sort of
happened along the way and and I want a
plan a band called no use for a name and
I was living up in San Francisco at the
time and and and that you know I've been
in that band about four and a half years
at that time so I kind of you know I
don't know I that time I remember
thinking like maybe this whole music
thing is kind of run its course maybe
this is as as far as it's gonna go and
then and then the Foo Fighter thing
popped up and it was how was bring in
the nineties Punk in the nineties was
great I mean that was the first time I
was ever in a band that that you know
had a following and people actually came
out to see and we to word and made
records and did all that stuff you know
it was it was great 20 cuz in the 90s I
disconnected from music because of my
commitment to commie right like I didn't
I really was I was up on whatever you
gave me you know I was up on Soundgarden
Superunknown and Badmotorfinger and
alive by you know the albums that were
at that time previously I would go to a
record store and buy everything now but
after the 90s it was just so fast for me
one minute I was listening to it comes
the rooster and then the next one it's
two thousand [ __ ] three and I'm
listening to the Foo Fighters you know
Nirvana once that tragedy happened in 94
so the later and nineties God I I lost
my music yeah whatever you know well
there was that thing you know like in
the early mid 90s when bands like Green
Day and the Austrian stuff got really
big right and so they were and so then
like major labels went out and signed
like all the punk rock bands and stuff
but the label that the band that I was
in was on was this label called fat
records and that was like you know I
mean I guess you'd think of it as like
indie punk rock whatever underground
kind of thing and it was and that scene
did really really well but it did really
well outside of the mainstream you know
I mean it's like none of those bands got
radio had like radio hits or were
featured in mainstream magazine or any
that sort of thing so it was like it was
a weird time because at the same time
that that sound was like really big
commercially there was still this
underground current of bands that
weren't me you know that never broke
through that mainstream that was like
the band that I was in another band that
you were and you did tours obviously oh
yeah yeah nationwide yeah yeah I mean we
that we you know we toured Europe a
couple times I opened up for a band Dave
was that one time well that was when I
was in high school actually yeah that
was that was so he was a male scream um
you know before he was in Nirvana and
they played in Santa Barbara where I
grew up and I was in a band at the time
called Rat Pack and our band opened up
for their band the woods tour and
Chinese restaurant I never had yeah I
never toured back then you know I never
like in in in high so I almost got it I
got a chance to join there was a local
band from Santa Barbara called arc al
rich kids on LSD and they were looking
for a bass player my brother Scott is an
incredible bass player so they really
wanted to get him in the band they they
called our house looking for him and but
I answered the phone
and so they wound up coming over and
playing me their new right they
just made this record that was like kind
of a groundbreaking record and in
punk-rock world called lifestyles of the
rich kids on LSD and it was [ __ ] nuts
like it was way beyond my ability they
can't remember bomber who was the
drummer and kind of the you know the
songwriter and leader of that band came
over and sat there my bedroom played me
all these songs and I just I didn't even
bother to try I just said dude I can't
play it was like that was my first
little taste of almost joining a band
that were like I would have gone on the
road and stuff but it was you know I had
to wait a few more years now years after
that when you were on the road with the
punk rock bands and stuff how was that
it's great just just the van yeah in a
van you know we had like an Econoline I
think it wasn't a psycho pop-top
Econoline it was a grace he's like I
never went anywhere when I grew up so I
was so eager to tour I just wanted to
get out and see the world I just wanted
to I didn't care where I was I'd be in
them you know just on some empty road in
the Midwest you drive by a silo and be
like look at that silo that's amazing
this is the best and you guys just do
like whiskey and go-go's across the
country that are like worse than VFW
halls and you know the Elks Lodge and
then an outing and you'd play a club
that had a decent PA or something but a
lot of time it was kind of it'd be
pretty low-rent so it's a long way to
the top if you wanna rock'n'roll yeah I
mean you know the craziest thing I mean
outside it just I mean if there's so
many crazy things about when I joined
the Foo Fighters but one of the great
things to me at the time was like I just
didn't have to load my gear anymore gave
my guitar to this guitar tech and then I
never had to see it again until it was
Showtime it was like heaven so what do
you think first out cuz I don't know
music that well there has to be a when
you audition for the Foo Fighters
there's a lot of people who can play
guitar really well well like what do you
think stood out free like why did they
choose you like what what what our bands
looking for when they auditioned someone
for someone I don't know you know it's a
funny thing because I've never asked
like I never asked devar the other guy
was like specifically why did I get the
gig you know I don't know I have my
theories but I think you know I'd like
to think that part of it was at least
that I learned the [ __ ] before I came in
okay like had it you know so it's looser
you how to play their songs you played
songs now I thought you might what it
might have played some like covers or
something no they sent me a cassette
tape for the stuff I was actually in New
York visiting some friends of mine and
and got a call from from Foo Fighters
tour manager Guus who was like hey we're
having auditions next week you know
we'll send you some songs if you want to
come down and do it so they sent me a
cassette tape and on the cassette tape
you see they had made the third record
with like learn to fly and all that on
it but it wasn't out yet so I didn't
know that record you know nobody knew
that record yet but so it was a song off
the first record a song off the second
record a song off the Godzilla
soundtrack that I hadn't heard but I
guess was out and then a song off the
unreleased third record learned to fly
yeah it wasn't that so it was a song
called Aurora no there was no yeah yeah
yeah now what was the album where the
drummer quit and then Dave had to go on
and do the tracks wasn't learned that
was the second record I was to say I am
that was a sec just great stories like
just how they put the band together yeah
yeah first guy join didn't want a tour
he split and then he came back yes later
yeah yeah but you're still the lead and
he's more of a rhythm guy I mean there's
not a ton of like you know info fire so
yeah I always get called the lead guitar
player but I just think I'm like to me
I'm just one of the guitar player it's
just amazing how much the music is
Shane's like when I was growing up you
had a lead right yeah everybody you know
that was like that was like when I was a
kid that's why I play guitar the way I
do is cuz I wanted to be a Straley and
Randy Rhoads and you know - well I want
to be one of those what did you look up
that were you first - no as ace frehley
was where's how [ __ ] good to say yeah
he's the man I'm a nice guy
I'm Randy Rhoads got Randy Rhoads was a
big one but I'm also David Gilmour guy
sure Dave Gilmour could take you to
places where I mean I liked all those
guys those guys I loved Ritchie
Blackmore was my really big boy for me
van Halen attitude move he can never
keep a singer right he looks like today
yeah he looks like a [ __ ] witch Yeah
right the fact that he's on the road and
should be shot
he's not touring to be purple right he's
talking about yeah you let me think that
me play like lute music or something
what the Polly looks like I saw a
picture he looks like a witch yeah it
was the witch hat the whole [ __ ]
thing I thought he was always I saw him
when I was young it was like rainbow and
like how he sounds really yes I never
got to see rainbow like thank that era
I'm me Ronnie James Dio for him it was
like that was that that lineup of RAM
tremendous yeah tremendous are what's
the one that took the to the to forget
the Alma
well there's I kill the king and your
change the good signs here long live
rock and roll the rock and rolling this
that one
watch one man on the silver mountain
that was a hit but then there's where do
we go since stargazer yes yes stargazer
I loved all that [ __ ] oh yeah you know I
love Clapton you got a love page some
little [ __ ] - yes sir
you know what you watch the live shows
out of New York you're like what the
[ __ ] was he thinkin yeah I was 1973 oh
yeah
so who were your influences basically
yeah I was like all that you know we
like I I was lucky I had all the
brothers you know my older brothers had
great record collection shows a lot of
stones a lot of Beatles and then you
know just all the classic artists
Zeppelin Aerosmith Ted Nugent Deidre
Hall that's a joke every savagery yeah
and then it sort of turned into like
Judas Priest and scorpions and all that
sort of thing Iron Maiden was a big one
in our house rush Scott went like deep
in a rush so that was that was dying
like Jake Lee we come out getting a
[ __ ] nerd whatever his [ __ ] honey
drummers one of the best in the business
at that time I still thought it was the
guy from the police I saw him live when
he was just [ __ ] amazing
yeah Bozzio from sure from Joe's garage
was always great I mean I liked all
those guys but as far as guitars I liked
I was a Gilmour guy Randy just yeah
flipped a [ __ ] switch yeah I was
there
and Van Halen opened up for the Sabbath
at the Garden Isle Royale and it was
like ye like silence you know
interruption not me and running for the
devil what you just knew was something
special but what I saw Randy when I
heard Randy I knew wrong do it different
[ __ ] yeah I was I just said you know I
never got to see him play live it's just
I was a little too young I didn't start
going to show it still like 83 so I
missed you know I didn't I didn't get to
see a lot of those but I still remember
the deal
Ozzy crossover yeah well deal was my
first that was my first concert it was
do it on his first tour no shame camp
yeah yeah Jimmy Bain have to see all the
man that line up this yeah unbelievable
but it was crazy how his uh the
crossover the Sabbath was really rough
for a lot of people I loved it I thought
having a hell was great right when we
pay his home I was the first one that
wanted to shoot deal pudding tab so as
much as I wanted to eight [ __ ] deal
I drove all the way to Philly and we saw
Sabbath with the young Sammy Hagar with
shakin street people were [ __ ] put and
spit on their fingers and fling on a bus
and a rock
Philadelphia has so much class when they
like didn't really they like you my
brother saw that tour it was the black
and blue towards yes Sabbath and blue
öyster boys to come join the blue I
think they played at Ventura fairgrounds
yeah midn I was a little too young to go
to that this yeah I have great memories
of my bluff cuz I share a room
my brothers do you I got two brothers
and they had the posters how are y'all I
said but I remember like a refundable
but yeah so my brother Scott was going a
lot of shows he went to he everything we
go down to LA and he did see Daniel
whatever he saw that stuff and I have
the like I have great memories of waking
up in the morning on like a school
morning and my brother being like sacked
out in the bed below mine and just
seeing his like crisp new concert
t-shirt from the night before laid out
on his
chair you know I just ride like I
remember seeing like the the mob rules
you know three-quarter length sleeves
just kind of draped over when I was
growing up you couldn't wear a car to t
food unless you went to the [ __ ] door
like people would stop it to me did you
go to that concert
take the [ __ ] sure how could you get
any of you didn't go to the concert big
no because people would still like if
you go to a concert bring me your shirt
oh well I was like there might some girl
had a shirt on some young girl at the
rec room and I felt like saying just
give me one arm but they wrote just hum
hum yeah and so I'm one [ __ ] song you
know my friend said he went to see the
Dead and boldly he's an old Dennett and
he goes you know this is a trick just as
a treat I wanted to treat myself you
know mayor is [ __ ] tremendous on that
tour let me go up the college there's a
couple years ago he called me like the
show started at 7:30 Colorado time which
is like 5:30 here I got a call like my
[ __ ] half hour later he said he had
to leave Red Rocks it was just a bunch
of rich white kids with [ __ ] the
Grateful Dead shirts on smoking pot and
that upset him he all he this guy
followed them you know this guy didn't
take showers for eight days to go to a
dead show and now he shows up he's all
these kids pulling up in BMWs with dead
t-shirt just ripped you know to show
them like they stop stop you're not
allowed in here
you can't wear that shirt okay you
didn't go to the show are you gonna wear
that shirt I saw they've got like a
Grateful Dead line at James purse that's
like our [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
kind of fun your friend out for the art
oh it bums me uh it bums me out
name one [ __ ] you know I had to
[ __ ] get on the bus and go see these
shows and fight Puerto Ricans to get to
get into New York City you know how hard
it was to get like ac/dc Def Leppard
tickets you know an eighty one eighty
like it was rough to go in there people
would take your [ __ ] remember the Ozzy
Osbourne some guy just jumped on my
friend and started dry humping
during the concert at crow beat of the
guy doing the [ __ ] forgotten [ __ ]
that hops get you earned that shirt
ironed that [ __ ] shirt I read the
first show that I went to that do show
you know this was in 83 so maybe a
couple years after that like all those
people have been trampled to death at
that whoo concert and Cincinnati and as
and I was like you know 12 or whatever I
remember just being in a car some some
crazy shits gonna go down it's being on
edge until the show kind of got going us
okay okay I think I'm safe oh my god
well and I'm I can't believe I'm
blanking on his name who was the guy who
came in here he does all the traveling
now he was in he's in heavier like I'm a
heavy metal band
and he said his fans used to punch him
during the show said worry no no he had
a little tattoos he doesn't the podcast
every wrong Henry Rollins he said he
used to get in fights mid-show he was
like yeah that was a different world of
wanna there's a crazy that's a different
world
that's that was eighties punk right yeah
I mean that was I'm sure he's you know I
can't remember the baby but I had some
rough times yeah that was the Black Flag
Black Flag Detroit black black that's
rough now as a kid when did you pick up
the guitar I start playing when I was
about eleven yeah and that 18 did you
have any dreams of the illusion yeah no
I kind of I kind of feel like you know
now that I have kids and no no I'm a dad
like like what no I'm saying like I I
feel like I was pretty lucky that I knew
what I wanted to do from her very like a
really young and now from like 14 maybe
it's like that's when it really like
that's when I started going to see shows
a lot and I was going down to LA a lot
to go see shows and I just thought you
know that like that's for me I want to
do that so from pretty much from that
point on I just thought I'm just kind of
counting the days until I turn 18 and I
move to LA and I'm gonna go you know go
make it is that exactly what you do the
a-team more or less when I turned 18 I
was kind of I had dropped out of high
school at the beginning of my senior
year and I just kind of [ __ ] around
and didn't have a job and was just
hanging out at the beach every day and
not really doing much of anything and I
remember about a week before my 18th
birthday my mom was like my mom was a
probation officer
up in Santa Barbara and she was like
[ __ ] this I got you a job on Monday go
see Linda down it down to probation and
you've got a job now ah so she basically
made me get a job would you like the
best thing that ever happened to me at
that point cuz I went and I and I got a
job the probation department is like a
just like a clerk okay you know in the
records room
filing [ __ ] and because of that job that
was right when I turned 18 and then I
worked there for maybe like six months
or something I saved up enough money to
move to LA I saved up enough money to
buy an amp and move to LA that's what
that's what that job did for me and how
many years did you go wrong kicking
around in bands oh I mean I first start
playing bands in like ninth grade and
played him lots of bands all through
high school and moved to LA and played
in a bunch of different bands and then
moved up to San Francisco in 95 and
right after that I joined their use for
a name and then you know that was their
money then were you just getting by uh
that was no use for name was the first
that was I coach you know I was paying
rent most of the time yeah well I had
like my nut was like you know 450 bucks
a month or something like that was good
you know yeah that was my luck
yeah that was like eight bill yes and I
still struck yeah we would come home
from tour you have a little money in
your pocket I'd have you know I'd be
good for a couple of months and then I'd
go get a job delivering pizzas or
working at the coffee shop or whatever
until we went on tour again and I did
that for pretty much the whole time I
was in Vegas
was it hard for you guys to start asking
for money for I mean comedy in the music
like was it weird no you you were good
at it you were just like my you know
it's funny you know it's funny you ask I
don't know what it's like for comedians
but in music
especially in America like you're really
kind of treated like a criminal and in
the club world until you you know have a
booking agent and you put records out
and all and even then still you know
that mean you'd go out and and they
don't want to you know nobody wants to
honor your right or give you any you
know yes for water and towels or some
beers or something to people like oh
[ __ ] rock star you know that old
thing right
which kind of blew my mind the first
time I ever tour Europe because you tour
Europe and it's they just have a whole
different system over there you know
where they just they do like they feed
you they give you all the booze you can
drink a Bud in the states it's really
hard man you don't get paid even when
even when you're relatively kind of
popular ban against out 50 or 100
tickets one you know I mean like you're
still not really it's hey I think it was
maybe easier when I was first starting
out I think it's much harder now well I
just look it with my own like my solo
touring stuff and it's like I don't
really have a huge draw or anything and
it's like I you know I know how I do it
it's kind of a luxury for me you know I
go and it's fun but it's it's a [ __ ]
black hole financially you know like I
don't know how any young band does it
it's nuts you know I don't know how
anybody gets a foothold any more years
ago don't I don't know the name of the
band now I know it they they were
popular in the early 2000s and they got
another guitar playing they moved on
there but a kid in my building in
Hollywood this had to be 99 was one of
the opening bands on that tour and he
basically said they did not get paid
right on this now sometimes people pay
right they were paying hey they were
their first band you saw there was two
other bands and then then yeah and they
were hot at the time just Cameron but if
the name doesn't come to me but they
were it was costing them to pay you got
it the music business 30 years ago today
is completely [ __ ] different
yeah there's no music sales thing well
you know the music sale in the mid 90s
you know when I was first starting the
tour you know you could still sell CDs
so the like our record label it was like
a small punk rock label so they wouldn't
cut us a check for tour support but they
would give you as many CDs as you could
sell and that was a sort of de facto
tour support and you would sell them you
know you got you those bands and in that
scene existed on t-shirts and CDs
because you just sell [ __ ] loads of them
at your shows and
that's how we we you know were able to
do it it's crazy how much music is chain
I was talking to Rudy and he was totally
Sarzo oh yeah we were talking about
white snow and he was a with I guess
Quiet Riot and somebody else you were
guaranteed a certain amount of money
every night in t-shirt sales hmm so the
opening band was guaranteed 750 a night
if you did four shows that was side
money and then the headliner was
guaranteed whatever 1500 a met a band
member why four shirts you know even if
doubt and they were doing arenas now
oh yeah the the numbers of I kept them
small because I want people think I'm
exaggerating or whatever but they were
up there I'm sure what they were making
they were also you also selling music at
record stores you know yeah now we've
done all those bands we're losing money
on tour I think back then do and now
it's completely gone the other it makes
my on tour well you have no choice
yeah choices you have to I saw them and
I saw a quieter I was the first big show
I ever saw it was Quiet Riot at the
Forum with with Whitesnake got to leave
a sale yeah quiet right it was
Whitesnake that when John Sykes was a
guitar player skräuss that was a good
show and now you're in the Foo Fighters
you've done how many albums with the Foo
Fighters another Jack it's a bunch
I mean it's 20 years the different
tracks on learning to fly did I learn no
no I didn't record on that right when I
was record on that was I'm the next
record one by one in recording that was
the first record according to Wikipedia
since seven
yes but on seven [ __ ] Foo Fighters
out I think so well how do you feel okay
pretty good you still feel like you made
it yeah I mean kind of yeah I mean you
know sure but I don't I'm just not
hardwired to to go like yes we've made
it no yeah I still feel like it any
minute like things could be
doron can be pulled out from under you
know I saw like your videos I watched
your videos and I saw one of your
pictures I'm like ela said I could buy
like a surfboard from you have no I do
have some for sale we'll talk after the
show you have no you didn't come in here
with a rock star attitude you just each
guy that yeah plays - [ __ ] ukulele
the guitar I know you love your guitars
yeah but I've seen pictures of you with
you know you're such an interesting guy
because I see a picture of you with a
Flying V you know there you are Michael
Shanklin jr. you're so like your great
friends would [ __ ] but you know [ __ ]
yeah you're in the honky Tonk yeah yeah
yeah odd cast yeah you interview country
people yeah you know yeah yeah it's so
weird how I see you on stage [ __ ]
jamming the best of you and then you you
know you just put out a song June 16th
and it's honky-tonk well it's funny you
know to me like the like country music
and rock and roll music are that far
apart and like you know I got a lot of
good friends and I you know certainly in
rocking and then in country too and it
seems like especially with country music
people there's so much crossover there
you know like so many of the people that
I that I know in the in the world of
country and Americana and all that are
you know people that grew up listening
in rock and roll music - so I like to me
they kind of go hand in hand but you
know I know like - - a lot of people
that like it might seem strange like
genre hopping but it doesn't feel like
that so much to me yeah you an artist
you're a [ __ ] art I'm an artist
goddammit
I'll do what I want didn't John Lennon
say if you gave him a tuba mmm you
figure out how to kill a [ __ ] sound
that'd right
Aaron artist yeah nothing more than I
love you know I love Duane I mean don't
get me wrong the singer was horrible but
I loved would [ __ ] Joe Perry left
Aerosmith and did the Joe Perry project
mmm you know I love when I see a guitar
player
drama well I see a [ __ ] nut the other
guy from Guns and Roses great guy
among the stuff yeah collaborate with a
shooter okay Lee you're telling me
something yeah yeah you're telling me
number one you're not a [ __ ]
knucklehead growing up if I came to you
that's up for debate if I come to your
house with opera a guy like you would
find the beauty of it sure do yeah yeah
well it's true for most musicians like
most musicians have I think have a
pretty broad musical tastes you know
most people that like sort of spend a
life in music noise [ __ ] that shocks you
that's what it is like when I when you
ask somebody what's your favorite like I
Mumbai saw this big black dude one time
with dreads and he came up to me at the
comedy since I came man
you shoot no longer she our denominators
Adam Sandler's my favorite I don't make
them aren't you in the Crips like how
was Adam Sandler your [ __ ] favorite
you a million people shocked me so
evenly yeah see musicians who they like
and who they support and you know even
like us Lee Walker we love Walker
you know you two different [ __ ] dudes
but you're the same he's an artist yeah
I figured out how to just write these
got great country music yeah yeah I
think that's why I think that's why his
records have done well you know like
those songs are catchy
yeah buddy cuz I interviewed him for
when I first met him as and when I
interviewed him for my for my podcast
and and my wife I was listening to there
was when his first record rake about you
know I was listening to it like just
kind of getting some questions and my
wife came home she didn't know that it
was like you know it's like it did she
didn't know that it was tongue in cheek
you know his lyrics and like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and all that stuff and she came
she said what the [ __ ] is this ignorant
[ __ ] you got so you met him I don't
think so maybe cuz she wanted me there
maybe not
she's always intrigued me when I you
know as a child and as a fan of music
when a guy takes off does something
that's completely different from them
what is John ray is chair that shows me
he's a true [ __ ] artist and that's
what is in his heart he enjoys playing
ever flute music yeah Joy's doing big 10
inch and [ __ ] whatever yeah and on
the weekends he dresses up like
spider-man Denis the violin oh [ __ ] I
tell you you know it's really true like
I did a lot of solo touring in the first
part of this year you know some of it
just full-on like just me and an
acoustic guitar and some of it with a
band and and weed you know like did a
lot of logged a lot of miles you know
for like pretty much the first half of
the year and then we went back and did
did a week of shows with foods in the
States and then just did a couple weeks
in Europe and it really does kind of
like it's that's one of the advantages
of doing what we do is the fact that I
that I do have the time to go out and do
these other things I can come back to it
I'm like it just kind of recharges you
as a player you know didn't
what's-his-name say success is going
from area to area with equal enthusiasm
MacArthur said that and it's really I
enjoy that dope yeah it's good when
you're sketched up to be atomic for
years I just saw comics getting whipped
every week Tuesday see a Sunday get home
Monday morning turn around do laundry
and I love doing stand-up I got nothing
against it but you know what I live in
LA I want to do movie from time to time
right and from time to time I don't
wanna go on the road I'm gonna do three
podcasts one week but I think that that
keeps me sharp
yeah I'm sharper than I've ever been
yeah well I was just doing stand-up all
the time I was just living in a stand-up
world I could just see just living for
the food you know just living for the
[ __ ] food and you know I think about
it now in hindsight if he would have
done that like if they would have done
that they would've probably still won't
Glenn Frey is dead like the Eagles there
was that six or seven years if you ever
see that what they went through with
like before the long run they had a hard
time and yeah the follow-up to Hotel
California and before that they had
mounds for all those three albums they
were together like it every [ __ ] day
well there's something was six or seven
years yeah like like touring all the
time it's like you kind of put your life
on hold yeah I don't want to see you
every day for three years I'm gonna but
eventually we're gonna disagree on right
yeah eventually we're gonna disagree in
and disagree in this agreement it's a
powder keg and then they didn't want to
talk to each other right well I see a
guy like Dan Feldman I wish that after
like Hotel California he would have done
Donna if they didn't want him to sing on
that [ __ ] song you know they'd screw
them all right fine you're that good of
a [ __ ] guitarist go get three [ __ ]
dudes and go put something together up
at the canyon Club right and and that
woulda gave that that situation
celebrity yeah that's why I think you
guys are so successful the Foo Fighters
because he's always that [ __ ] is
always doing something yeah bro you look
at him he's always doing something oh
definitely he's in Cuba playing conga
drums he's you know Virginia doing this
yeah and you know pretty much everybody
in the band is like in one way or
another and I think that probably you
know it's gotta have something to do
with with the longevity of the band you
know everybody kind of goes and
scratches whatever it's they need to
scratch and then you come back and and
you're good to go when you're going on
close to 17 years 20 years 20 20 years
yeah Wow
yeah Jesus Christ oh you still sound
better than ever I mean so is part of
you doing so touring is and I know
you're not gonna say you get sick of it
because you eat but how what does it
feel like to be on tour and you're doing
songs they wrote 15 20 years ago does it
this do you still get enjoyment out of
that is it more exciting to play new
stuff yeah I mean I think of course it's
always more exciting to play new stuff
because like you know you don't know it
as well and there's a little more
that fear factor okay when you've got a
new album and you're trying to remember
that you know it's just less muscle
memory that those are the songs that
give you that little rush like oh I'll
but don't [ __ ] this up you know
oh come but you know at the same time
like you know all my life and ever long
it sounds like that always you know it's
always great you know right I mean we
it's we're not the type of band that's
gonna come out and do like you know
weird jazz versions of the songs you
want to hear and all that sort of play a
bunch of like obscure b-side it's just
not what we do and I don't think that's
what people want to see right and you
know nowadays it's like to come to for
anybody to come to a show is like you're
talking to tickets are expensive parking
get a sitter just kidding and let alone
you buy beer and a t-shirt or something
that's like $8,000 yeah you can't like
not play learn to fly because maybe
you're you don't feel like it that night
you know I mean like you got it you
gotta just bring it every night and I
think I don't I think Dave's really
that's one of his gifts as a bandleader
it's like he gets up for if you could
see him before we go on stage he's like
bouncing off the walls for like an hour
and I think that that's just how he gets
like he gets gets it gets going you know
to lead the charge he's a true performer
Alfre sure and you know like I've read a
little bit about him his early stuff
would Nirvana and stuff like that he you
could see he enjoys it definitely
there's a lot of people had do it for
the drug this is longing for the Broads
you know it's one thing to really you do
it for those things but we enjoy right
right but it's it's one thing to be up
there you know and really be having a
great time I just on the plane right
back whatever last week I had not much
everything I downloaded I had watched
and I watched Rolling Stones from
Netflix hmm and towards the end of the
thing there in Cuba and he's doing can't
get no satisfaction right yeah
I'm selling the plane I got an edible of
mainland wines and [ __ ] I'm like
forty years he's been singing I can't
get those
fraction you know yeah how do they go
out and still have that enthusiasm I can
think about is the audience the audience
you know sure I was watching the Queen
movie for a little while I was watching
that in 60 minutes and I don't know what
stadium they had done Queen
they put Romney whatever his [ __ ]
name mister the singer put the tape in
and there was a minute there where the
whole arena was singing some I forget
the song right now you know sometimes
the energy that you get from the crowd
how many times what you think I hate to
come on to be funny every [ __ ] night
oh you think you want to be funny every
night but when you're listening to the
audience and you're in the back and
that's why don't like a bunch of idiots
and the green won't talk and get the got
it I'm listening to that audience you
might be talking to me I'm gonna listen
to em agree but I'm listening to that
audience and that audience is getting my
dick harder in the harder so sometimes I
love you know you sit there and you know
how can you do the peanut joke again
Joey I get do people they don't want to
hear you do you know there's nothing
worse than going to see Santana you know
like you're gonna Hollywood ball you're
gonna see Santana you're ready for
[ __ ] you know not all a comb-over but
the other one and also he's like this is
a new song I wrote about Mexicans
crossing the border listen same that
poor [ __ ] save that for the jazz bar
in our border right on Mexican night
today you're doing [ __ ] it you're doing
Samba Patti yeah well I'm gonna throw a
[ __ ] fit here and it's true you said
play 200 sheep going into one of these
they don't want to hit Dave go this is a
song I wrote I was rollerskating
[ __ ] out it sing that funky music white
boy I tell you we you know do you
mention the stones we we got to back up
Mick Jagger a few years ago on on SNL
which is like the greatest night of my
life and and you do we did a few
rehearsals throughout the week with him
and and you're talking about how does he
get up to play those songs forever he
would come in every day and go like hey
I'm you know my voice a little little
sore I'm just kidding I'm gonna get it
kind of lay off a little bit and the
minute Taylor would count the song and
he just became [ __ ] Mick Jagger to
like he couldn't not be Mick Jagger you
know he became migizi he just he would
and every time I said I'm just gonna lay
back in never took it like he just went
full you know 110% you're madly bang
23-year old we grew up a big fan
big-time big-time yeah that they're like
my ultimate really really go catch them
and Pasadena
I'd like to yeah yeah when is that kick
I think they rescheduled think it's
still August 20 something that might I
think we're I think we're on overseas at
that point have you watched that Rolling
Stones now is that good yeah I guess
hear them going through South America
alright and learning all the different
dialects in the countries and him coming
on talking [ __ ] in Spanish yeah he's
brilliant does he pull it off he pulls
it off yeah when he goes to Q but he
pulls it off yeah when he goes to these
places he could see him how he gets a
report he does research on the town so
you could talk [ __ ] that's a comics turn
up in a couple local references yeah
yeah I mean letteth skin it goes to how
a Bama they're not gonna open up with
[ __ ] you know whatever they're gonna
open up with Sweet Home Alabama share a
couple people so sleep what do you think
about all these music movies come now
like I spend it like the one that really
that
it interests me is that beetles one
we're like oh yeah that's kind of a cool
concept where like ever no one remembers
the beetles do you guys as a band think
oh I'll be kind of cool to have a movie
based off our music or I mean I would
like to hope that were many years away
from having a movie made of us but you
know - I mean yeah that'd be that'd be
pretty I I love the Queen one and in
large part probably because I'm not a
crazy diehard Queen fan that knew all
the stories and they have you know knew
that where they took license right well
I mean I like I like I like I didn't I
didn't know like the I didn't I don't
know the details of how they came up so
I could just kind of watch it as a
casual fan whereas like you know like
Pat and Taylor who know all like what
that's wrong that's wrong they comboed
that you know I mean I think maybe work
you know saw it differently even though
I think they liked it too but uh but I
thought it was great and it got my
youngest son listening to Queen
constantly which I thought it was great
and then that kind of turned him he like
I don't know turned him into a little
rock and roll fan so I thought it was
great but like you know most of the time
with those movies if I know too much
about subject matter I can't get past it
like I tried to watch that Netflix
Motley Crue movie and I could I've made
about half an hour and I can't [ __ ]
watch thank you like because I was like
the biggest [ __ ] Motley Crue fan ever
and I couldn't just I couldn't
there was no I just couldn't look at
those guys pretending to be my league I
just couldn't do it I don't know why you
know there was no what's what's the term
I'm looking for office police pension of
disbelief yeah I couldn't I just
couldn't get there you know that's
interesting yeah like why would you hope
that it would be a while to get a movie
based on the plan because we're still
here we're still doing it it's too soon
what the beat what's the beat oh I don't
I think it's like the one person
remembers the great except in an
alternate universe and he's the only one
that remembers the Beatles The Beatles
didn't exist but he knows all the songs
so he he starts he becomes a star doing
all the old Beatles hits I haven't seen
the movies or what happened
but it was just like they like they have
the entire soundtrack and walk him
honestly think there's nothing about I
watch the trailer there's nothing no
offense to anybody involved that but
there's like nothing about it that
appealed to me but okay
so oftentimes with those kind of things
like you watch it and you're kind of you
see it on a plane yeah that one's a bit
okay not like I like that Dad opening up
I really enjoy one of the things I
really enjoy about what I do on this
podcast is when I play a song that I've
heard 20,000 times and when I play it I
get 20,000 people ask me what song is
that right and it could be burning up
from how bad to love it you know yeah
nothing bothers me more that people
really don't know the original five
album [ __ ] monster the Aerosmith this
right you know from that first time to
that night at the ruts which a lot of
people didn't like I'm not a big fan of
it either but nobody really knows like
get your wings nobody really knows that
you know it's so weird that you say that
because I saw them at the Forum a few
years ago and it was really like 90s hit
heavy reset and people were [ __ ]
losing their minds and I had that same
realization like wow none of these
people even know [ __ ] the only was a
good [ __ ]
they don't then why would I play and
they're not clamoring to hear it like
you know what I mean like they would
this has been the thing that has I love
music podcast I love doing them I trying
to do one or two I try to get Dean
Delray in one just I remember the first
time me and Bert Kreischer spoke about
Guns and Roses on here that we played
don't cry in November rain people were
emailing me for weeks because they only
know welcome to the jungle they know the
new generation just knows that you know
I played uh what was Sammy Hagar Ronnie
Montrose oh yeah you know Space Station
number whatever 18 yeah the next day
people lost their mind
Prince sign of the times there are
certain songs I John and Hall and Oates
I can't go for that
Jesus people lost their mind you know
kin what was that for egg can't ya Jeffy
you know there's been so many songs that
and it makes me like go
holy [ __ ] so now when I wake up in the
morning I play the three songs that are
on my mind whether it's Cowboys from
Hell you know he uh I play a couple Foo
Fighter things but a lot of people know
the Foo Fighters like everybody knows
but this band you might Michael Shanklin
you have full lights out they jump on a
[ __ ] window
you know they jump out a window when I
play live you ain't oh yeah it's really
weird and that's why I get mad sometimes
because [ __ ] don't flag me and
they'll say I'm gonna get sued and I
can't see a band getting mad at me
well who who Flags you YouTube Oh for
real yeah yeah this was different
I'd have on [ __ ] hablas on right now
with videos are you breaking down where
you got the riff from alright right I do
it with you yeah yeah do it YouTube
Yanks it flips it I want to see kids to
get educated on we know this is what
it's yeah you're when you hear blow up
the outside world you could tell Chris
Cornell was influenced by that's the
Beatles what the outside world is John
Lennon basically I write like a little
bit so I want people to know but that's
the that's the tough thing oh yeah and I
hear it all the time people call in to
Eddie trunk and [ __ ] they yell at them
and they're like there should be more
radio stations it would [ __ ] all the
music these kids and I this is like this
is like the thing with it seems like you
know every time we do an interview now
people why are there no rock bands what
happened to rock music where's all the
rock bands and it's the same things like
to you know there's a million of them
like just why aren't they getting
mainstream exposure you know there's
tons of rock bands out there it sounds a
great rock bands great rock you know why
why it's that they're not in the
mainstream in this day and age I don't
know you know why I have why when I read
Keith Richards biography
but he made a great read Facebook a
couple years ago he made a great point
we don't even make live albums anymore
right no bands make live albums anymore
because of the technology we've
forgotten how to wire a drum right
they're like they forgot how to wire if
I have you read that their chapter in
the band we got so technological that we
forgot the basics well you know it's it
is interesting to read that somewhere
along the lines you know with what
digital recording and everything it
because the emphasis started getting
more on like making everything perfect
and everything's gonna line up perfectly
and you know that's the reason all the
albums that we've been sitting here
talking about sound the way they do is
because they weren't perfect at all they
were one [ __ ] up you know shits out of
whack and so that's what makes it sound
the way it sounds and did we get win we
all got away from that I mean that is
one of the like things I really like
about you know these last couple solo
records I made with this guy I don't
know if you're familiar with Dave Cobb
who's the producer he's done you know
tons him like Chris Stapleton and people
like that but he records like the way
that you make those records there's no
click track you everybody set up in a
room recording live that's like all the
basic tracks and it's it's like you know
it's still recorded in Pro Tools not
like it's like super throwback or trying
to be retro or anything but the sort of
the the heart of it is is it's less
picked over you know
how was the recording and the writing
process of the Foo Fighters eight I mean
it's varies from album to album for sure
I mean there was a couple records we did
that we recorded everything on tape and
that was really fun because you know but
you just have you know you'd get like
one I get like one guitar track instead
of like when you're recording in Pro
Tools you get like there's many guitar
tracks as you want and then we'll figure
it out in the mix you know kind of thing
so it was fun you know you pretty much
we each got like one track you know and
you'd have to do whatever you were gonna
do on on that one track but it was cool
because you'd like you know if you we'd
be punching in with different pedals and
different amps and different sounds so
that one track would go from like you
know kind of jump all over the place
I'm in the writing processes it Dave
yourself it's usually
way it goes like Dave writes a bunch of
stuff yeah well he'll have a bunch of
riffs and and song ideas and stuff and
he'll usually go record them just him
you know playing everything and he'll
send those out to everybody and then we
all kind of learn them and then we get
together and jam on them as a band and
and just kind of jam on them and record
them and he kinda you go you kind of
work on it until usually we'll do that
for a while and then when he feels like
everything's ready to go we'll jump in
and go record it for real what are you
guys doing not touring yeah we we just
got home we're just over in Europe and
did a bunch of festivals and did a
couple of couple of our own shows we
played like we'd never been a Croatian
we played in this old Roman like
gladiator arena place well in pula that
was [ __ ] my blood was like small but
like it was a ruins it was incredible
it's like so cool
so we just did that and a bunch of
festivals and then we've got a couple
more weeks in August and then a couple
of things here and then we're going to
South America and Central America and
and September October I think it is and
how long will that two ago no that's
that's I mean that I wouldn't even call
it a tour it's like I think three or
four shows something like that so that's
it yeah just kind of quick and then you
know we the couple weeks in August is
probably seven or eight shows or
something like that to then you come
back and you do your own thing now I'm
not sure yeah I got I have with my thing
I'm doing some shows this week actually
around Southern California in like Costa
Mesa and
out of happy and harriet's and then
Bakersfield and then here in LA on
Sunday and and then I've got I haven't
announced yet but as well announce it
now I'm gonna do a couple weeks in
September of my own shows so ran
throughout we're around like I think it
starts in outside of Denver and then
goes through the Midwest a little bit in
the south winds up an Americana fest in
Nashville
now what's your show on your own mostly
it well it depends sometimes I go out
and do just me and a guitar
yeah and that's like acoustic and that's
fun I like doing that but I'm you know
as a
guitar player I want to be able to play
off of at least a play off a rhythm
section you know so I can play leads and
stuff so I for the for the shows in for
the shows around town this weekend I
just threw together you know a new
lineup of dudes and we've actually been
rehearsing the last couple days and
trying to learn the songs and get it
together so fingers crossed I want on
the Foo Fighters website it you know
gave me up but then give me a lot of
stuff do you have your own website oh
yeah yeah yeah what's that website it is
what is it Chris Shiflett music.com
where are you playing in Bakersfield we
have a lot of people in Bakersfield now
right it's that I think it's called the
temblor brewery yeah oh really oh cool
yeah I've never been that's a great
point yeah I think it's right by the
Crystal Palace yeah that's [ __ ] you
yeah you've been on yeah Justin guy
brother I mean did you ever think it
would get to this I mean there's no limo
there's no body
you mean the [ __ ] fool five yeah now
you do the podcast yeah we'll have you
been doing that for I've been doing it
for a few years now it's I started in
2013
no yeah and went but when I first
started like you know I didn't know what
the I'm still don't know no no probably
what they're doing right yeah but so so
when I first started owning I would put
one up and then I wait like a month and
a half and I put up another one and then
I'd wait two weeks I put up you know
what I mean I had like no sort of set
thing and then I take four months and
not do it no you know I mean I was just
real like kind of jackass about it and
then there was a certain point where I
realized [ __ ] I gotta be consistent with
this and I started doing every week and
now I did that for like a year I did it
every week and that was like too much
and then I backed and now I do about
every two weeks although I haven't put
one up for for a few weeks right now
I've been too busy yeah between the Foo
Fighter tour and getting ready for these
shows I just haven't a time but I'm
gonna not know I usually put them up on
Monday so not next money but I think the
next Monday I'll probably no name in the
podcast it's called walking the floor
walking the floor now it says that you
put country artists yeah a lot of
countries country Americana roots but
you know rock stuff to also get hung
croc yeah I just kind of you know
whoever I kind of want to want to sort
of expand beyond just you're gonna do
musicians you know I think it'd be fun
to just talk to anybody who else if you
had on that would rather guess that has
Lucinda Williams and Twite Yocum and
Merle Haggard I got to interview yeah
I've got Marty Stewart Rodney Crowell
Sturgill Simpson wheeler Walker of
course I interviewed I mean so many
people Jason as well tons of it
influence you in the country like who
did you hear and say wow like for me
with Johnny Cash hey Johnny Cash was the
entry point for me because you know like
in all that Sun Records stuff between
like Elvis and Jerry Lee Lewis and all
that stuff but like Johnny Cash was
probably the first like country country
artist I ever listened to and and but
the big ones for me or like Merle
Haggard and Buck Owens are probably the
the kings you know Merle for me yeah I
love my friend of mine that always
played Merle in Colorado yeah she's so
good
heroes her best songs he really did his
lyrics first it was just a different I
don't know country like I heard about a
tool one time that like Kris
Kristofferson and those guys isn't
responsive by Budweiser Budweiser like
cut him off midotaur
they've had drank as much beer you know
those those type of stories at my dick
guard yeah like I could care less about
heroin and all that [ __ ] there when four
guys I think it was Chris I don't even
know like the four that the other dudes
he was with but all those type of
stories I love all that [ __ ] you know
yeah I think it's funny with with
especially like the honky Tonk Aaron
country where they the image that they
projected was this very clean-cut
wholesome family churchy
kind of thing and those guys were
drinking whiskey and taking tons of
speed and [ __ ] everything that movie
like they were the biggest fuck-ups of
all you know I mean I think there's
there's something so classic in that you
know the way that's presented to the
world came along there yes what Islam
yeah they were going harder than
probably most of the rock bands at that
time no they always had like those all
the women moderated beehive
in the back you're an extra interesting
guy man this has been great yeah I don't
want to take more time but yes sir
people have a podcast they show up early
yes what is it so weird
yeah I'm even surprised that how about a
meal well it's funny you know la it's
like it's like I live on the other side
of town and I had to run a couple
errands before I got here you know it is
like it might take you an hour and a
half to get here or it might take you 20
min you just never [ __ ] know in this
town you know it's like you try to plan
your - yeah who knows you know it's
always a mystery you're such an
easygoing guitar player
yeah I'm trying like you try it tell my
wife that she keeps calling me an
[ __ ] how long have you been married
I've been married what is it 16 years
now yeah and the kids
my oldest about to turn 16 and and then
I got a 12 year old that's about to turn
13 what do they think about getting away
or being the [ __ ] Foo Fighters
I think that they are are they thinking
I don't know if well I
they definitely think it's cool they
don't really tell me that though you
know they talk [ __ ] didn't you hear him
on the phone like flop you my dad and
the full file now I've never heard him
do that but like you know my oldest
figured out like yes sometime in the
last year or so like oh [ __ ] my dad can
get free concert tickets dad I need
those tickets to that Tyler the Creator
show at the forum go get them you know
like that kind of thing that's when it
clicks for my kids I can just see yeah
it's got a cool job I can see your dad
Thomas who could [ __ ] you in the Monkees
the [ __ ] I love it hey listen
anytime you want to come on right on
what's the name of this last song that
you just released there's Oh welcome to
your first heartache or there's at the
album that what else yeah it's hard
lesson yeah my glasses yes that a single
that's that's the album that's the yeah
yeah when did that get released that
came out June 14 so last month so that's
what you two
yeah yes got out yeah all right man
there's the last time we're gonna
release a podcast
now this next week but the week after
you promise yeah I swear to God we will
find out have them listen don't forget
to listen to Chris Jeff ilat I'm walking
the floor I mean ya know we covered
everything I wanted to ask you there was
nothing that want to ask you out of this
world
I like say now you let me are you doing
this like you don't have to edit it
afterwards you're actually the video
yeah the video works would you grab
because that's the part of podcasting I
[ __ ] hate the most
it's going back and listening to it and
like slapping it together for a release
yeah I mean that that's a hard part
about keeping it consistent as the more
stuff you add to it yeah the one the
last thing I kind of wanted to ask is
you you mentioned that there was a point
right before Foo Fighters where you were
considering quitting well I wasn't so
much that I was considering quitting I
just sort of was seeing the thought that
I was seeing I thought that it had
peaked for me you know what I mean like
I was like I dropped out of high school
like I said I went I went to I took like
some classes at San Francisco City
College and we had made a new record but
we hit we wasn't out yet and just kind
of had this little moment of light mmm
you know my dad always said I could move
move in with him and he'd pay for me to
go to school maybe I should kind of
think about just kind of doing a left
turn here but and then the Foo Fighter
thinking about none of that happened how
so I think I was what 27 28 when I
joined the balance 28 when I joined
foods yeah it's a [ __ ] perfect day
yeah I feel like it was a perfect age
because I wasn't I wasn't like 19 and
yes you know I mean cuz hey who knows ya
know were the perfect day and already
slept on a few floors yeah exactly yes
it was now one of four seasons oh the
day I got the gig our tour manager goes
hey you want me to get you a room at the
Sunset Marquis we're staying there I was
like what
just in my own room were you married at
that time
no baby no I had a girlfriends I heard
not you not my wife no no no yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] she left
she left she was a nice girl she was a
nice girl she ever call you anymore say
now I'll be back I love you buddy yeah
pleasure it's been a real play and then
you guys II and thank you very much for
coming on any dates
give me some dates okay yes okay so
Wednesday the 10th in Costa Mesa at the
Wayfarer and then Friday the 12th at
Pappy and Harriet's out in the desert
Saturday the 13th at the temblor in
Bakersfield is a great place yes I'll be
there like in Vienna and then Sunday at
the Moroccan lounge here in beautiful
Los Angeles downtown you're [ __ ]
beautiful
I will be Thursday Friday Saturday and
Charlotte North Carolina nice at the
beautiful and the [ __ ] tremendous
comedy zone you bad [ __ ] I want
to thank Chris I want to thank the
flying Jew but most importantly I want
to thank you guys do not forget I will
be at the comedy zone and Charlotte this
weekend five great shows Saturdays close
to selling out and then the ninth of
August I will be at the Lincoln Theater
in Washington DC
that's how we do it we're keeping the
summer light ticket too cheap $28 and
Charlotte take a chance Columbus dead
you're gonna have a [ __ ] great time
also the Church of what's happening now
is brought to you by for hems calm a
wellness brand for men whether you
suffer from erectile dysfunction you
losing hair you having problems with
skin care for hims is there for you
you've heard us talk about four hymns
and how they're helping guys look their
best if you haven't yet it's time to see
what they're all about the best way to
prevent hair loss is to do something
about it while you still have some it's
time to get a handle on those precious
locks I asked you do you want a bald
spot to pop up on your hairline and to
receive or do you want to do something
about it first
why do guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science the solution for
you is for hems doc
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness okay no snip no
snake oil pills no gas station counter
supplements no more awkward in-person
doctor visits for long pharmacy lines
for hims connects you with real doctors
online which could save you hours
completely confidential and discreet you
answer a few questions
a doctor will review it and if determine
its right for you they can prescribe
your medication to treat hair loss and
it shipped directly to your door it's
that easy
get the hair loss treatment everybody's
talking about it's been featured in GQ
Men's Health Esquire Playboy just to
name a few
now today right now the church family
can get started with a complete head kit
for $5 Joey five hours five hours five
hours five hours at four hymns calm
slash Joey C website for full details
and safety information and while
supplies last because I know if I got a
deal like this frie dolls he'd be going
off the shelves this could cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor but
know with four with four hymns calm we
got you go to four hems calm slash Joey
that's four hymns calm slash Joey the
church is also front to you buy on it
listen when it comes to supplements on
it is the king from the protein powders
to the CMT oil to the alpha brain which
they give you hundred-percent money-back
guarantee and you keep the product who
does that nobody but on it that's why I
believe in them I trust them and I love
them Aubrey is doing a phenomenal job
down at the honored center be a part of
it going on it calm right now take a
look at the great supplements they have
to order if you're finds up go to the
box and press in charge and get 10% off
your order delivered right to the crib
nobody gets their feelings sure you
understand me listen I want to thank you
guys for the continued support you know
I love you guys are all my heart I'll
see you in Charlotte but most
importantly I see you Thursday morning
or Wednesday morning ready a rock
tip-top [ __ ] Magoo we're coming
into Charlotte big time alright now I
want to play a little song for you from
Chris Shiflett
his new album hard lessons I love you
guys thank you very much for listening
for taking the time kick this [ __ ]
melee